because you're running a business
there's money involved but you're also
friends but you're also training
Partners is there um attention that
money creates that can threatens to
destroy friendships
that's something I always worry about
with money I try not to go do any kind
of business with friends or family
I think if you're all very clear and
honest and open at the start makes it
much easier I think people have issues
when there's like kind of like things
are written and fine print and nobody
knows the exact answers
and a lot of Jiu-Jitsu guys can't read
yeah that makes it we're learning that
today yeah hey
uh no
um definitely complicated though
yeah I mean it's not always obvious to
how to be transparent and stuff and
about everything
um have you felt that tension because in
the Jiu-Jitsu World money is not really
unlimited just running at school what's
that like is this the first time you're
running a school
running a gym
yeah I mean it's just constantly
updating people about what's going on
what your expectations are
you know I mean we've had some problems
with coaches who I feel like think the
pie is bigger than it is yeah you know
what I mean they feel like uh maybe
we're getting rich out of this and
they're missing out on things so it's
like even amongst managing staff that
can be challenging too so yeah I mean
it's a constant work in progress to make
not only to make sure everyone's happy
but to make sure they're comfortable
enough to reach out and tell you they're
unhappy but I feel like those challenges
are common amongst any small business
still it sucks
uh just to mention I'm clueless to this
but I'm just not learning this
uh somebody I met and talked to and I
really like is Isaac
yeah just learned because you're also
active on Reddit what's your name on
right John Belushi's mom as on the cover
as possible you know oh it's not you
it's uh it's actually it's actually John
Belushi's Mom right
uh so I've done my research I guess and
I guess you guys had ahead of falling
out and have split I just want to say
that
I don't know the few interactions I've
had with him he's a beautiful human
being so and that just shows to me
visually maybe not internally and
sexually just the experience I know uh
she's just a kind person I don't know I
like them a lot
like to me in a business setting
um yeah tensions are created and it
sucks
I don't know
I mean I I suppose money all the stuff
that happened in the jungle aside
probably money had a role to play to
create extra tension money and egos
about like who is the leader who is not
the leader it's tough it's tough to
manage that kind of stuff I've seen it
happen when Jiu Jitsu schools a lot I
don't know exactly what because it's
like there's also a hierarchy inside
grappling just the schools like people
that are better or not there's literally
ranks black build and brombo there's
like competitors that are better I mean
I don't it's a weird dynamic in which to
operate because like usually there's
more politeness and like Humanity
layered into the way a company works but
here there's just a bunch of I mean it's
like violence laid on and on display
plus money
it's crazy is there something you could
say to that like how you try to minimize
or something you want to comment on
Isaac yeah I mean it was unfortunate
situation but it just didn't work out
you know like there's gonna be
personality clashes
some people uh I can't imagine anyone
having a personality clash with you with
me yeah it's hard to imagine yeah
surprising
you know I mean I I didn't even know
what to say on that I don't want to
touch on it too much but obviously
his expectations about his role in the
gym obviously different from house uh
led to some personality clashes that
were sort of unresolved you know some
things happened that can't be resolved
he can't fix those things yeah you know
uh obviously a lesson I hope for both of
us definitely a lesson uh for me from a
management role to try to address these
things sooner but also sometimes I came
up in a different time where there was
no money no opportunities I had to pave
that I had to pay that way totally for
myself especially coming from Australia
like uh being a professional athlete in
Jiu Jitsu was not I think so I had to
pave a lot of opportunities for myself
and I feel like sometimes uh
oh I don't know what the right word is
sometimes people don't appreciate some
of the ways you help them and they just
think feel like almost they deserve or
are entitled to certain things and that
is very difficult to manage but I think
again like we we both see the situation
different I do hope he finds a better a
more comfortable place to train but yeah
obviously I've known him for a long time
sort of like a a brotherly relationship
so that's going to really
make personal problems a lot worse when
you're that close to someone you know I
just hated that like I've seen in Jiu
Jitsu especially but in other places
where like close friendships were
destroyed because of like gym stuff
like people running gems and it's just
as a person who is in this case just a
fan but in like in general just like a
student it's like sucks but again in my
position sometimes I wonder if there
really was a friendship or mere
opportunity I have to be careful of that
with some people in the sport yeah is it
a sincere relationship or like I mean
it's difficult for me to tell or am I
means to an end
sure but I think it's actually a
trade-off because I think a lot of close
friendships we have like even
relationships we have
like when tested
like can break if they're not properly
communicated like some of it could be
just misunderstanding of like for for a
long period of time
um not not it's not explained totally
just like a lack of Integrity it's just
like you like you have to like talk
through that [__] like just be honest
with each other take some MDMA or yeah
drugs solve everything if you've learned
anything from this conversation I've
actually haven't done MDMA yet uh people
say that that's something I would enjoy
a lot because my brain is I think
natural on MDMA
um I'd recommend it for sure for sure
um is that what you do with Gabby and
Valentine okay
um she drugged me
in general why is there seem those seems
to be drama in the Jiu-Jitsu world like
outside of outside of what's going on
here or is that just uh I guess
Universal to anything dramas everywhere
and then drama Rises to the surface okay
I'm gonna makes the money yeah I wish
there was a little bit less